hey you dirty Birds welcome to the most
awkward book signing ever is this he
taken of course it is mister now that we
finished another hefty scoop of Castle
Rock it's time to take a deep dive into
season two's ending
unlike season 1 which left us with a
pretty ambiguous and Annie's journey
isn't as open-ended yet still leaves us
with many unanswered questions you'll
want to stick around for the whole video
as all be going over if joy was actually
possessed by a MIDI what happened to
Annie and how the kid ties season 1 & 2
together
so grab some ice cream because here we
go episode 10 begins right where we left
off in episode 9 Pop's body is taken
away to undergo the weaving process
after a shot him in the head pop will
later be imbued with the spirit of a
French set learn aimed at Tian remember
that these spirits can access the
memories of their vessels which is
exactly what ace wants from pop pop has
information about the angel information
which was previously held in these
letters between Allen Pangborn and de
Lacey
but since pop burned the letters the
info now exists only in his memory only
in memory back at the Marston home that
tells people including joy are still
hypnotized by the statue of the kid
now here's unanswered question number
one how comes some of the citizens can
hear the sound that hypnotizes them well
others can't in episode 9 apti asks this
question but no one seems to know one
theory is that those unaffected are on
antipsychotics since we know drugs seem
to have a dampening effect on this
spirits powers this still wouldn't
explain characters like chance or Nadia
who to my knowledge aren't on anything
at all the second theory is that those
who do not hear the voice are considered
unclean or not worthy of being in a
madhi's army an army which a says will
soon take over the world upon a Maddie's
return I think this is the more credible
theory especially since ace calls the
noise the voice of the angel and that it
and the sound of the skismo which we
heard more about in season 1 are one and
the same pop is put into that goo where
will later see that his bullet wound has
been healed which also likely means that
his
answer has been cured as well but this
was all part of Pop's plan last episode
we watched him inject Haldol into his
body to stave off the weaving process he
then has to put some acting chops on in
front of ace gaining his trust so that
when he's assigned to track down and
kill Nadi and AB D he can save and help
them in their quest to blow up both the
Marston home and crypts beneath the
construction site it's here we learn a
little more about the angel aka the kid
and the skismo ace refers to Castle Lake
as a door to other here's now's and
dimensions I'll get more into this and
the kid later on in the video
papé sacrifice when he later frees
chance and chains himself to the wall to
die with the Marston home is the end of
his redemptive arc he's lived most of
his life with the secret that he killed
Nadia and Abdi's mother while on a
mission in Somalia adopting them out of
guilt for what he had done in Nadia's
eyes he's irredeemable if I lived
through this night I'm gonna leave this
place
I'm never gonna think of you again but
judging by her reaction when she has to
say goodbye to pop I'd like to think
that he was in some way redeemed joy is
prepared for the ceremony
notice how they've dyed her hair black
remember this point for later on the
dagger which Amity used to kill all the
villagers in 1619 is also placed in
front of her tomb the ceremony as ace
tells the followers will be the end for
Castle Rock but the beginning for them
Annie tells Nadia NAB D that if they can
destroy that statue maybe it'll get the
townspeople to snap out of their trance
so what better way to do that than a
[ __ ] ton of explosives
but Annie couldn't care less about the
townspeople all she cares about is joy
something that will become evident when
she tells a stayer plan in order to save
her Nadia NAB D managed to plant the
explosives with the final bomb going to
pop in the Marston home joy is brought
out to a madhi's tomb while the kid
emerges on the cliff by Castle Lake
seemingly to take in the events that are
about to transpire
Nadia blows the explosives killing pop
and lifting the townspeople from their
hypnosis this is the last we see of
Nadia abdi chance and ace I had hoped
for a little more closure
especially for Nadia and Abdi like even
if Nadia said something to pop like
I love you it would still leave it
ambiguous whether or not she ends up
forgiving him which is really what their
story is about if anyone can bring me
back to life
q we also don't really know what happens
to all the French settlers I doubt all
of them died in the explosions so Castle
Rock may have some 400 year old French
spirits walking around now the story
picks up one week later with joy and
Annie leaving Castle Rock and instead of
our recap of the final portion I'm gonna
go right into whether joy is a MIDI or
not since it will cover most of the plot
points in the final half of the episode
first off this question is purposely
left ambiguous by the writers however
unlike last season's ambiguous ending as
to whether the kid was actually evil or
not there are way more clues and
evidence to support a definitive answer
that being that joy actually was
controlled by a MIDI now what I'm going
to do is lay out all the evidence on
both sides of the argument and leave it
up to you to decide however I know which
one I'll be picking to start things off
we know that a MIDI is supposed to
inhabit Joy's body at dusk we see dusk
occur as the Sun falls into the horizon
over the Marston home we don't know
however if more of this ceremony needed
to take place or what the exact
definition of dusk is now perhaps the
most damning evidence against joy being
a MIDI is that she ends up stabbing ace
is it that she didn't know he was
actually augusten was she confused did
the kid tell her to do it as it was part
of a bigger plan we simply do not know
we then get any rushing towards joy
embracing her but joy does not return
the hug or even really look like she
knows Annie now it's possible she's
still traumatized or still getting over
this hypnosis but contrast this to
episode 8 when Annie saves her from the
Marsten addict and she's 100% returning
the hug and ecstatic to see her mother
let's also talk about that black hair
the same color as a madhi's later on in
the episode and he says they can go get
some hair dye to change it back but she
says no why would joy not want to change
her hair back after it was dyed by a
cult is beyond me from here until the
end of the episode
so joy is increasingly distant from
Annie always turning her back on her and
getting away at every chance she can get
of course that could also just be
because of their past and that she's
still not over what annie has done to
her at a gas station any witnesses joy
seemingly flirting with a boy but it's
been hinted at several times in the
season that joy has a thing for girls
specifically chance however that is
never really expanded on this ties into
a nanny catches joy watching a lesbian
film called blue is the warmest color
now is she watching it because she likes
that sexual component of it or is it
because it's in French this ambiguity is
brilliant on the part of the writers
let's also take into account that joy
tells her mother she'd rather live in
Montreal perhaps because there are more
french-speaking people there even though
Montreal is a big mix of French and
English but back to the gas station
because we have to point out that Henry
Deaver poster in the background which
basically confirms that this season
takes place in an alternate dimension
you'll notice here that the missing
poster says Henry was last seen July 7th
2019 let's go back to the final episode
of season 1 we know the events of that
show take place in 2018 and the final
few scenes of the last episode including
a Christmas scene with Henry and his son
take place a year later
aka 2019 how could Henry be missing in
july 2019 while also spending Christmas
with his son and taking care of the kid
in 2019 the alternate dimension theory
would also explain why when ace went
looking for the kid at Shawshank he was
nowhere to be found back to the question
of joy and Amity and he takes a job as a
caretaker for someone who is bed bound a
fun nod to house show later care for
Paul Sheldon the author of the misery
novels annie reads a very curious
passage from the novel listen carefully
as she talks about how the character
Gregory came back a different man and
her emphasis on his eyes Gregory had
come back from the Crimea a different
man it was his eyes
they didn't look out at misery anymore
they looked in at something only he
could see eyes are what any fine
scrawled over and over again enjoys
drawing book eyes that look like they
could be the kids or aces we also know
Amity love to draw inside her notebook
are some creepy lines like he who winks
his eye is plotting and I will lead you
where you do not want to go they are
both Bible verses since when was joy a
big bible thumper or say knowledgeable
about the descendants of God Adam and
Eve even Annie's employee says of joy
when she's walking away from Annie
hormones hit it's like a strangers
living in your house hey he's a stranger
amedy inside joy any later overhears a
telephone call between joy and a mystery
caller now the letter any later finds
says it was a lawyer she was talking to
in the hopes of being emancipated but
joy isn't Annie's daughter remember
they're sisters so why would she need to
be emancipated
now I've listened to the voice on the
other end it doesn't sound like ace but
it's possible it could be him since we
don't see him die or perhaps Henry
Deaver which I think may be more of a
stretch we simply don't know that also
brings up the question of the letter if
joy is actually a MIDI is it possible
the letter was a complete fabrication in
order to keep Annie away perhaps the
biggest evidence to support joy not
being controlled by a MIDI is Annie's
hallucinations
since we're seeing this all from her
perspective and we know she's prone to
hallucinations it's hard to gather what
we're seeing as true or not we know that
she is still haunted by the whispers of
her mother after the events of Castle
Rock the irony of this ending is that
Annie Kills joy by drowning just like
Annie's mother Kris Hilda tried to kill
her drownings a motif throughout the
season young Annie almost killed baby
joy via drowning way back in episode 5
Annie ends up giving Haldol to joy but
we never see it take effect perhaps
because it takes time to metabolize when
it's ingested rather than injected it's
also ironic that Annie is stabbed with a
pen a writing tool after Annie discovers
this letter she goes back to resuscitate
joy which works and they live happily
ever after
well not quite it's safe to assume
everything after Joy's drowning is a mix
of
and fantasy joy hugs her mother and
tells her she saved her joy has finally
found her laughing place and they enjoy
ice cream and joy isn't interested in
the other kids this is what any wants in
her mind it's her laughing place and
it's only when we see her father and
mother in the Paul Sheldon reading that
we see joy too is a figment of her
imagination
Annie livin in blissful ignorance of the
horrors she's committed in some ways
misery is the perfect allegory for
Annie's life the only thing that brought
any joy was joy a joy she ended up
destroying her life therefore became a
misery but how does this connect with
the events of misery the film and how
does she eventually get to Colorado well
first you'd have to take into account
whether these two stories take place
within the same dimension if they are
it's safe to assume she would continue
living on the run in her mind
with her imaginary joy later settling on
a remote Colorado ranch where she'll
eventually save Paul Sheldon then
there's the question of the kid who we
now know can traverse these different
dimensions using Castle Lake as a portal
I personally believe he's an evil entity
that can influence the events around the
areas he controls aka Castle Rock he's
always wanting to expand this influence
after he realizes his plan with Amity
was foiled he simply disappears back
into a new time and place kind of like
how young Henry Deaver and Molly strand
were able to do in season one it looks
like the kid will be the through line
for all the seasons so expect his real
identity to be kept secret however many
think he could be Randall Flagg or the
Crimson King the latter being an
immortal being which could explain why
he never ages I wouldn't be surprised if
he shows up X season now we also can't
forget Jacki Torrance we saw her at the
end of season one on her way to Colorado
to work on a story about the Overlook
Hotel I thought for sure she'd tie into
any story since Annie also ends up in
Colorado but if they're in different
dimensions that may not be the case I
really enjoyed this season of Castle
Rock but now I open it up to you I want
to hear your thoughts in theories
any comments below what did you think of
the ending please take a moment and give
the video a like every little bit helps
and I hope to see you all next season
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much